hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt von mir und ich wäre sitzen jetzt
ein bisschen auf der terrasse wir haben
heute schon ganz viele rezepte gemacht
für unser koch und backbuch und haben
uns jetzt eine kleine pause gegönnt
und ich wollte die gelegenheit jetzt
einfach mal nutzen dieses video zu
machen
ich habe heute schon auf facebook ein
gewinnspiel angekündigt und zwar geht es
um die kate world messe in wien
die findet ihr ja dieses jahr statt von
11 bis 13 september und ich freue mich
da auch schon richtig drauf denn nach
berlin habe ich in wien die meisten
zuschauer
deswegen freue ich mich auf euch ich
freue mich darauf endlich mal eure
gesichter zu sehen und ein paar namen
kenne ich ja auch das heißt er ist auf
jeden fall kommen alle von denen ich den
nutzernamen kenne und das ja immer was
ganz tolles für mich wenn ich dann auch
noch meine zuschauer selber treffen kann
auf jeden fall gibt ein ganz tolles
gewinnspiel und zwar hat die firma deco
packen tolles set zusammengestellt
zum einen gibt es die küchenmaschine die
kenwood zu gewinnen mit sämtlichem
zubehör was man jetzt hier so sieht
ich glaub sogar noch ein bisschen mehr
dass mein ganz großes paket dann bekommt
ihr zwei karten für die cag volt messe
in wien und natürlich auch die
übernachtung dazu im marriott hotel das
heißt für das ganze wochenende könnt ihr
auf die cache world messe nach wien
kommen und habe da eben auch das
wochenende dort dann gibt's ein gutes
paket von deco barg das heißt sie haben
ja alles für trocken dekoration vom von
dort über lebensmittelfarben und so
weiter wird ein ganz großes paket
zusammengestellt und an einem abend
gehen wir dann auch mit euch zwei also
mit den mit dem gewinner und der
begleitperson eben auch noch zusammen
essen da könnt ihr mich dann so ein
bisschen kennenlernen und mein team
an welchem tag genau dass man sein wird
entscheiden wir dann spontan
beziehungsweise klären das einfach
vorher unter uns und auf jeden fall
finde ich dieses zeit richtig genial
ihr könnt daran teilnehmen schaut
einfach mal auf der facebook-seite von
deco back vorbei ich verlinke euch die
seite auch unten noch mal hier unten in
der video beschreibung in der infobox
und da könnt ihr auch direkt teilnehmen
die kompakt wird dann auch direkt diesen
preis verlosen und ihr meldet euch dann
einfach wieder zurück und ich bin dann
auch schon gespannt wer gewinnen wird
und vor allem wenig daneben dort treffen
werde auf der messe werde ich alle drei
tage sein
also wenn
ihre daherkommt dann können nämlich dann
auch sehen ich pack und kocht dann auch
ein bisschen was aber ihr müsst dann
auch verstehen
ich bin ja gerade schwanger jetzt habe
ich aktuell noch neun wochen bis zur
geburt und wenn wir auf der messe sind
sind dann nur noch 5 das heißt ich bin
dann nicht mehr so fit wie zum beispiel
in friedrichshafen oder in hamburg und
deswegen müsst ihr verstehen dass ich da
auch ein bisschen eine pause braucht
zwischendurch aber der moral ist ja auch
da und mein team ist da und die können
das dann alles ein bisschen überbrücken
während ich mich dann kurz ausruhen kann
und dann eben wieder für euch da bin
ihr merkt auch jetzt schon ich bin ganz
außer puste sich einfach mit
anstrengender geworden
auf jeden fall freue ich mich wenn ihr
da jetzt mit macht und ich drücke euch
an natürlich ganz fest die daumen
und ich bin schon gespannt wer gewinnen
wird und freue mich auf die messe bis
dann